there has been a drone strike on a
building in russian-controlled Donetsk
Ali Hashem is there
I'm in front of a building that was hit
with a drone attack just after midnight
here in dunyetsk it's not the only
building that was hit but there is also
a church that was also reportedly hit
there are no casualties as we understood
however this attack is significant
because it's the first time that a drone
is used to attack a Target inside the
city of Dunes actually this is the Heart
of the City the Vera
Swarovski neighborhood that's a one of
the Posh neighborhoods here in the city
it was as reported it was hit with this
drone now we're gonna show you a bit of
what's left of it
this is one of the Wings there's another
Wing the same length it's uh around two
meters this is around one meter there's
another one also these are what's left
of the of the Drone this is the
motherboard also some other parts you
can see some bullets inside this
handmade drone as we understood now
there is a context also for this attack
over the past few days there were
several artillery
attacks in the neighborhoods of of
dunyards or several people injured as we
understood also and there are also
attack attacks outside the city however
today this attack coincides with another
one in Moscow and the third one in
Crimean at train station but according
to Russian authorities all these attacks
were thwarted al-jazeera